[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it is
the bible
the word of god welcome to bible answers
live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello listening
friends would you like to hear
an amazing fact june 11
2021 lobster diver was entirely
swallowed by humpback whale off the
coast of massachusetts
but he made it out alive with only minor
injuries
michael packard 56 told wbz
tv he was 45 feet down in the water off
provincetown
when all of a sudden i felt this huge
shove
and the next thing i knew it was
completely black
he initially thought that it was a shark
but realized he didn't feel any teeth or
pain
i could sense i was moving and i could
feel the whale squeezing me with the
muscles
in his mouth i was completely inside and
it was completely black he added
i thought to myself i'm done i'm dead
packard says he thinks that he was in
the whale's mouth for about 30 seconds
but he was able to continue breathing
because he still had a scuba tank on
in an effort to save himself packard
said he began rocking within the whale's
mouth
before the animal surfaced and ejected
him
packard's mate josiah mayo saw the
creature burst from the surface and
initially he thought it was a great
white shark also
he plucked him from the water and then
ferried the day's diver to a local
hospital
humpback whales which can grow to 40
tons are toothless
filter feeders who corral schools of
fish or shrimp before taking massive
gulps
their throats are actually too narrow to
swallow a human
experts believe packard was accidentally
enclosed
while swimming too close to the whale's
dinner
fortunately packard experienced no
serious injury
but did you know the bible talks about a
man who survived three days and three
nights
in a whale stay with us friends we're
going to learn more on this edition
of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
welcome listening friends to bible
answers live and we're so thankful that
you've tuned in
if you've got a bible question we'd like
to invite you to give us a call
the phone number is 800 god says that's
800-463-7297
and we're also streaming this program on
facebook you can
watch what's happening here in the
studio on the doug batchelor facebook
page the amazing facts
facebook page and the amazing facts
youtube channel
and you can text your friends right now
and tell them to call in with their
bible questions
we don't have all the answers but we'll
do our best to search the word together
and define the truth call now 800
god says 800-463-7297
i am doug batchelor my name is john ross
good evening friends and pastor doug
it's always a joy to be able to study
the bible together
before we get there you spoke about a
remarkable story of somebody that was
swallowed by
a whale and yet survived this obviously
is not the first time that we've heard
stories about people being swallowed by
a whale
of course you have the bible story of
jonah but you also have in more recent
times back in the
16th 1700s there have been stories of
fishermen that were swallowed by
orwellis that were swallowed by a whale
and yet they survived even
being swallowed down into the to the
whale's belly and
they they killed the whale and pulled
the guy out so
it's not uncommon i guess it's not a
rare thing
to be engulfed by a whale although this
was incredible yeah
well the baleen whales like the the
humpback and the blue whale
they can't but then you have the sperm
whales they eat giant squid they can
definitely swallow a person hole and
that was a story i think you referred to
of a guy named james bartley
who was actually swallowed by a whale
recovered about 20 hours later still
alive
and but you know the bible tells us the
story of jonah you've all heard it
friends and people say well it's just an
allegorical story and it isn't really
true it was just
a metaphor a fable to teach a lesson but
if you read in matthew chapter 12 jesus
talking about the story of jonah
he says that it is very definitely real
he says for as
jonah was in the belly by the way this
is matthew 12
and you can read in verse 39
he said it's an evil and adulterous
generation that seeks after a sign
and no sign will be given except the
sign of the prophet jonah
for as jonah was three days and three
nights in the belly of the great fish
so will the son of man be three days and
three nights in the heart of the earth
and that's also referenced in luke 11
and
of course the story of jonah so it is a
true story and friends the wonderful
thing
about the story of jonah jesus said it
is a sign
real quick story of jonah he's sleeping
in a boat during a storm jesus was
sleeping in a boat during the storm
and they wake him up and jesus was woke
up
after they wake him up the storm is
calmed jesus calms the storm
they cast lots over jonah they had jesus
they cast lots at jesus cross and
it says that they turned these gentiles
turned to the lord because of the
sacrifice of jonah
and then it tells us jonah
after three days and three nights he
comes out alive
jesus from his betrayal to his
resurrection
he suffered for the sins of the world
three days and three nights
and then christ said this the giant
jonah is a sign to this generation
jonah went to nineveh says it was a
three-day journey
and then it says he preached in 40 days
it would be destroyed
but they repented jesus preached three
years
actually it was a three and a half day
journey for jonah jesus preached three
and a half years
and in 40 years jerusalem was destroyed
so he was
a living sign to that generation we've
got a book that has that and a lot more
will send anybody
for free and it'll strengthen your faith
in the power of god the book is called
the sign of jonah written by pastor doug
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and you want to ask for the book the
sign of jonah and we'll be happy to get
that in the mail and send it to anyone
who calls and asks and you'll be blessed
by reading that
well pastor doug before we go to the
four lines it's always good to start
with the word of prayer so let's do that
dear father once again we are grateful
that we have this opportunity to open up
your word and study together and father
we ask your blessing be with those who
are listening wherever they might be
whether they're traveling or
maybe at home father be with us here in
the studio and guide us into a clearer
understanding what the bible says
for we ask this in jesus name amen amen
once again if you have a bible related
question the phone line here at the
studio is 800
463 that's 800-463-7297 if you don't get
in
right away you are on the queue and
we'll get to your call as soon as
possible so just stay on the line
we're going to go to our first call of
this evening we've got anthony listening
in new york anthony welcome to bible
answers live
how are you good how are you good
i'm doing fine
my question is based on 2nd
thessalonians
chapter 2. um
i guess we can start in verses 9 through
10. i mean there's a little bit of
context there but
9 and 10 is specifically
question is coming from well let me go
ahead and read that for everyone anthony
so that uh those who are driving can
can get the scripture it says ii second
thessalonians chapter two verse nine
it says the coming of the lawless one is
according to the working of satan with
all power signs and lying wonders and
with all unrighteous deception amongst
those who perish because they did not
receive a love of the truth that they
might be saved
and for this reason god will send them
strong delusions that they should
believe a lie
that they all might be condemned who did
not believe the truth but had pleasure
in unrighteousness
so what's your question is it about god
sending delusion
well actually
you know you're cutting we're having
problems anthony your phone is cutting
off and on you're
jumping in and out um i'm sorry can you
hear me better now yep that's better
okay great sorry um i know the bible
also says that if it were possible even
the very elect will be deceived by this
strong you know by the deception of
satan i guess i'm wondering
how do we prepare ourselves to be able
to distinguish between
one one thing i will also say is that
we'll know that the holy spirit will be
poured out
and that there will be miracles that
people will be doing as well in the last
days
so i'm just wondering how do we
distinguish rightly distinguish between
the miracles that are as a result of the
fruit of the spirit
versus the deception from satan because
the
you know we see it even going on into
you know the world today
is there just a sure-fire way to know
one versus the other
well i think there's a list of tests
that we apply to know how to discern
between the two and the false christ
said for one thing
you'll know them by their fruits moses
tells us when you're telling the truth
from a false prophet
that if they prophesy and their prophecy
doesn't come true then they're clearly
not a true prophet
also if their lives are not in harmony
with the truth you know there's a lot of
wicked people and they say that they're
prophets
and it should be in accordance with the
word of god you know their other
teachings would then
line up with the word of god sometimes
people say they've got a prophecy and
the prophecy may even come true but
they're getting it through astrology
or through some kind of mysticism and
well right away you know that
it's not a prophecy of god so uh there's
a number of tests now i think we have a
lesson
that we can send we do that has all
these tests that you apply to a true and
a false prophet
and if you'd like to receive that study
guide one of the amazing facts study
guides the number to call is
800-835-6747 and you can answer the
study guide it's called
does god inspire psychics and
astrologers and we'll send that out to
anyone
who calls and asks again that's
seven 800-835-6740 seven and ask for the
study guide talking about prophecy does
god
inspire psychics and astrologers and
pastor doug as you mentioned you've got
uh
five key criteria and that's listed in
the study guide that will help
guide people to know the truth from era
thank you for your call anthony we got a
call coming in from
emmanuel from ghana africa emmanuel
welcome to the program
good morning hello hi
hello yeah lisa my
question this morning is in genesis
chapter 2
verse 17 and
god told adam that the day they
eat the fruit of uh good and evil
they shall surely die but after eating
they didn't die at the spot so i'm
asking why didn't they die at the spot
after eating the different but add only
to 950 years
yeah well first of all they did die they
did begin to die
spiritually and in hebrew when it says
you shall surely die
the way that translates is in dying
you will die in other words they would
begin a death process
as soon as they sinned and that's that
happened you know right away you notice
that their glorious robes
the light went out that covered them and
they saw their nakedness
and um they they began to feel shame and
blame
and uh you know the dying process
happened thorns and thistles came out
on all of creation began to suffer the
other thing to keep in mind
is that with god it says a day was is
like a thousand years and a thousand
years like a day and that's psalm 84
it's also second peter chapter three and
no man lived more than 916
years that was methuselah meaning they
all died in that millennial day god
lives
forever so when he said in the day that
you eat thereof you'll die well they did
die within that first millennial day
but they did begin dying that very
moment they sinned
the process began and also the moment
they send a substitute that very day a
substitute was found to take their place
where the lamb was sacrificed and they
were given the coats of skin
had that sacrifice not been available
right away
they probably wouldn't have lived very
long at least not the 900 years
yeah that's right the the lord covered
them with
skins something had to die okay then
probationary time
thanks for calling manuel we've got
charles listening from florida charles
welcome to the program
hey pastor doug pastor ross how are you
all tonight doing well
well my question is this right now we're
living in the end times we're very close
to jesus second coming
my question is this how do i spread the
gospel
if i don't know the bible still all that
well
well you know there's varying degrees of
understanding
and when we start out we are babes
in the word we are saved babes
you can have very simple faith you know
paul and silas told the philippian
jailer
he said believe in the lord jesus christ
and you'll be saved
and he had you know been a pagan jailer
he probably
there's a lot he didn't know paul stayed
in his house he dressed his wounds he
taught him and then there's growth that
happens after that
so when a person can understand and
embrace by faith the simplicity of the
gospel the holy spirit helps them
to grasp that they can do that even as
babies and then grow in their
understanding all different levels
you know pastor reminded number there's
another story where
jesus healed the demoniac and he wanted
to follow jesus
but jesus said go back to your towns and
your family and your friends
and tell them what i have done for you
so one might not have a full
understanding of all of the various
prophecies of the bible but you can
share what jesus has done for you
in revelation chapter 12 it talks about
those who overcame by the word of their
testimony
so if the lord has blessed us if we have
a testimony we have an experience
that's where we can start we can begin
by sharing that testimony amen
thanks for call charles we got paul
listening in arkansas paul welcome to
the program
hey pastors can you hear me we do
okay wonderful um two questions same
context
i called another q a ministry out of
texas summer trucker
and uh i asked uh i understand to be
received the judgments
and there were rewards uh then he
corrected me
said it wasn't rewards it's reward
and then my second question was uh if
uh what would our reward or rewards be
that's the difference from uh maybe uh
stronger believers and i was using it as
an example of
billy graham and myself well he went
into the parable
of the youth vineyard owner and how he
hired
them at 6 00 am and 6 pm told me
jesus is an equal opportunist i thought
that was a
parable to tell people that no matter
how late it is
you can always receive salvation so i
never got an answer
is it reward or rewards because i always
hear other
uh preachers saying rewards and
is there a difference of our reward or
rewards
uh for someone who like billy graham 50
60 years and yourself 10 years
thank you yeah good question um you know
some of this might and i don't want to
you know
judge the other uh commentator but
you know technically we're salvation is
the broad
reward that the redeemed receive
everybody receives
salvation and in the parable of the
vineyard workers
christ is really telling the jews do not
be
jealous that here you've served me for 2
000 years as a nation and now i'm giving
salvation to the gentiles
right out of the gate so that
parable was really for them but christ
is clear that there are varying degrees
of reward
because there are also varying degrees
of punishment i mean jesus says great
will be your reward in heaven to one
group
and he talks about in the judgment he
says those who had two talents that
turned it into four talents
they're they're gonna get uh rewarded
those who took the five and turned it
into ten they're gonna get a greater
reward he says i'll put you over ten
cities
so there's several parables where jesus
says there's varying degrees of rewards
he also said the person who did not know
his masters well and disobeyed
is beaten with few stripes but he who
knew his masters will
and still disobeyed is beaten with many
stripes so both
in punishment and in a prosperity or
blessing
it seems there are varying degrees of
rewards and if you look at the verse in
revelation 20 to 12
jesus says behold i'm coming quickly and
my reward is with me to give to everyone
according to his work
yeah now we know that we're not saved by
works we're saved by faith
and yet we are rewarded by works so just
as each person has different works
there are different rewards for example
you might have somebody who gives their
life
as a testimony of their faith they marty
for their faith in jesus
their reward in heaven might be a little
different than someone who lives a
fairly good life but maybe has never
really been involved in bringing
somebody else to christ
at least not sacrificing to that same
extent
so there are varying rewards based upon
our works and yet our salvation is based
upon our faith
and even on earth jesus every now and
then he'd look at somebody like the
centurion or this
syrophoenician woman he'd say how great
your faith is
so he he recognized varying degrees of
faith even during his earthly ministry
is that helpful you know it does and
thank you because uh
that answer was not even close to uh
what i i got
and uh you know uh because uh
if billy graham did have a butler and i
did it when we get to heaven i'm okay
with that
yeah me too i just want to be there
that's right
that's right and you know what also the
parable you're absolutely right the
greatest reward
is that you sit on the cross so we can
receive salvation everything after that
triples that's right that's just the
gravy and of course you're also reading
the bible that
the redeemed in heaven take their crowns
from their heads and they lay it at the
feet of jesus and they say you are
worthy to receive praise
yeah so there's going to be no selfish
ambition in heaven for sure
uh next quarter that we have is patty uh
or patty calling from
georgia patty welcome to the program
thank you thank you for taking my
question um
since sin is the transgression of the
law and it's important to know what the
law
is is there anywhere else to
look for the law besides the ten
commandments and what got me thinking
about this
is james chapter two verses i guess
eight through ten
it mentions um loving your neighbor as
yourself and and
calling that the law and you know saying
you shouldn't break the law
and i my understanding of um loving your
neighbor as yourself
doesn't i don't think that's in the ten
commandments so i'm wanting to be sure
that i have i know where to look for all
the laws
yeah good question well first of all the
law
is divided in a few different ways the
ten commandments
are an expression of the supreme
law of love the first four commandments
deal with our love for god and you know
jesus said love
all the law is summed up in love the
lord with all your heart and your
neighbor as yourself
the last six commandments are talking
about the horizontal love relationship
between us and our neighbor
you know don't steal from your neighbor
don't kill don't take their spouse
don't covet their goods so forth so uh
the ten commandments are really a great
summary but you find the principles
of the law paul said you know all the
laws summed up in this
to love and maybe you were looking
something up were you going to read that
yeah i was just going to add actually to
that the very passage in james chapter 2
verse 8
where james says to fulfill the royal
law you need to love your neighbors
yourself
and then just three verses down he says
he gives an example and he says
for he who said i do not commit adultery
also said do not murder
now if you do not commit adultery and
yet you murder you have become a
transgressor of the law
so it's quite clear in james's mind that
when he says you shall love your
neighbors yourself he's referring to the
principle
that sustains the ten commandments
somebody came to jesus
one day and said what's the greatest
commandment in the law and jesus said
well there's actually two
the first is to love the lord thy god
with all your heart soul and mind
and then the second is to love your
neighbors yourself upon these two
commandments jesus said hangs all the
law and the prophets
so the first four of the ten
commandments have to do with our
relationship with god
and the last six have to do with our
relationship with our fellow man so
in one way the ten commandments defines
what love
is it tells us how do we love god how do
we love our fellow man that's right
well i was thinking about murder if you
put it on a continuum love would be at
one end and murder would be at the other
i mean i've thought about this before
okay well i think i i don't think i need
to be too worried that i don't
that i need to look somewhere else
besides the ten commandments just keep
looking deeper
yeah well you you do have the ten
commandments and that's of course the
moral law you do have what they call
civil law and there were laws that said
you know if your neighbor's donkey
wanders off bring it back that's of
course a law of love
there are health laws in the bible uh
and you know
most of them are common sense about
sanitation and not to eat
scavengers and things like that but um
so you know i don't want to make it
sound like it's just the ten
commandments god does have
laws that get a little more specific we
have a lesson i think that talks about
this we'll send you for free
it's called written in stone and it
talks about the ten commandments and
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who calls an ass the number is
800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the study
guide it's called written in stone and
we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who
calls and asks we've got oscar listening
from new york oscar welcome to the
program
oh yes sir hey 2 corinthians 5
21 i would like to know what does the
word righteousness mean
in second you go ahead second
corinthians 5 21
yeah it says for he made him who knew no
sin to be sin for us that we might
become the righteousness of god
in him i what does righteousness mean
i don't understand okay good now when it
talks about
he god the father made him jesus
capital h who knew no sin christ was
pure to be sin christ took
all the all the sin of the world in
himself
for us that we through faith in him
might become the righteousness of god in
him
when we have faith in christ we then
are given credit for the righteousness
of christ
and that's called justification and then
out of gratitude for that we also then
from then on want to live holy lives and
that's called sanctification
but just by coming to christ and faith
he'll wash away all of our sins because
christ who knew no sin became sin for us
that the righteousness of god might be
in us
and if you want to look at just the word
righteousness it simply means right
doing
so you know the law requires right doing
or obedience of the ten commandments
we've all fallen short of that we're all
guilty of sin
jesus came and he perfectly kept the law
he did
right he did righteousness and then as
pastor doug mentioned that great
transaction where we give jesus our sins
by faith
and he credits his right doing or his
righteousness to our account
so that we stand before god just as if
we'd never sinned
and the technical term there is
justification so righteousness simply
means right doing
and paul is talking to the to the
believers um while he's talking to the
jews in particular and he says you're
trying to obtain a righteousness
based on your own works and you're
neglecting the righteousness that god
has already provided
in jesus and his appeal to the jews
accept christ righteousness that's the
righteousness that saves amen
i think we can squeeze in one quick
question before we've got
phil listening in new york phil welcome
to the program yeah thanks for taking my
call i appreciate it
um was solomon's temple the first
jewish temple a real place did it
actually exist
and the reason i ask is because
apparently
even to this point in time there is no
physical
nor archaeological evidence of its very
existence
okay thank you very much was the temple
of solomon
a literal temple well first of all if
you believe
the historic accuracy of the bible you
can read there
in first kings great detail about
the temple of solomon david basically
had raised the money for it
he prepared a lot of stones and gold and
silver it gives the
dimensions and the design as a very real
place
as it was being built and that's both in
uh first kings and is it uh first
chronicles as well i believe
and um pastor ross and i we were in
israel together a couple of years ago
and they took us on a private tour
down below the stones that were built by
herod the great
and they take you to the foundation
stones that actually date back to the
time of solomon
so i know there are some there are some
people in israel that say well
we dispute that those stones were there
from herod or from solomon they say it
was
built later but then there's a lot of
archaeologists that say no
these 50 ton stones are
they go back to the time of solomon so
i think there's abundant evidence i
think they even said they found the
quarry
because solomon it says they quarried
the stones and then they drug them
to the um the building site all pre-cut
there's a lot of detail about
construction for us i think that's a
total fabrication so
i think there is also tangible evidence
in the quarry
hey thank you very much phil i
appreciate your question hope that helps
a little bit
probably you're not going to have time
oh there's the music we're just we're
not going away
we're going to have more bible questions
the best is yet to come so
tell your friends to tune in and with
their bible questions we'll do our best
in just a few minutes
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
hello friends pastor doug batchelor here
with amazing facts
karine was divorced pregnant and very
concerned about her future
but god saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion
and he used a co-worker to share an
amazing facts dvd
that led carine to our website here at
the website she studied our
life-changing free online bible studies
what she learned there transformed her
heart and today
karine has a lasting peace she's
baptized and part of a nurturing church
family
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today
and to make an eternal difference for
more people like kareem
your simple investment of faith and
amazing facts
will keep growing and reaching more
people with god's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know christ
and the wonderful truth that changes
hearts and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at
877-506-1751
the number again 877 500
or just visit give.amazingfacts.org
or send your gift to po box 1058
roseville california 95678 thank you for
studying the word of god with me today
and i hope that you'll plan now to join
me again next week
as we discover more amazing facts from
the word of god
want to know god's plan for our world
and solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
bible study guides
provide encouraging bible-based answers
to questions on healthier relationships
when jesus will return and much more
prefer to watch while you read
our brand new prophecy encounters dvd
series makes the perfect companion set
order your study guides and dvds today
by visiting afbookstore.com or by
calling 800-538-7275
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
god and his plan to save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800 463 72
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome listening friends if you've
tuned in along the way this is bible
answers live and we do as the title
suggests we do our best
live to answer your bible questions now
pastor ross he's got a little
notebook in front of him so he sees
there's callers waiting i have no idea
who's calling or what the question is
and so i'm hoping i get a notebook like
that one of these days so i can see
what's coming in
but we're not going to dilly dally we're
going to get to the phones if you have a
question here's the number
it's 800 god says 800-463-7297 for your
bible questions
and we're also streaming right now if
you want to see what's happening in the
studio
that would be the amazing facts facebook
page or the doug batchelor facebook page
and you can watch as well as listen
there pastor
we just like to keep you on your toes
that's why we don't give you your own
little notepad here
all right next quarter that we have is
carl listening from canada carl welcome
to the program
uh good evening gentlemen thank you for
your work for the king
a question uh
the what's the best response to what i
see
as a rising um rising
doctrine within christian circles uh
about
jesus only that is only jesus jesus is
the father jesus
the son jesus is the holy spirit what's
the best response
yeah that's sort of a type of modalism
basically saying god changes his he can
change his mode there's one god and he
can put on the jesus face of the father
face of the spirit face
well probably one of the best answers
for that carl is if you look at the
baptism of jesus
you've got jesus the son in the water at
the very same moment that god the father
is speaking to him
unless jesus is doing ventriloquism and
then the holy spirit is coming down
as a separate entity upon him and you
know jesus says go baptize in the name
of the father the son and the holy
spirit
and so um christ all the time is there
on earth
sometimes jesus speaks and then the
father thunders from heaven he says i
have glorified your name and i will
glorify it again.
so there over and over again if you just
read the bible as it's written
without doing all these theological
gymnastics you can see that there are
three distinct individuals christ talks
about the spirit as he when he the
spirit has come he
will lead you into all truth and i must
leave that he may come
and it's it's really clear we have that
book
on the trinity that really it will also
pull the rug out from under the oneness
teaching
now i don't want to be unkind i know
i've got a lot of friends i used to go
to
i was telling pastor ross that i used to
go to oneness church
and um you know there's some dear
christian people
but they are really hung up on the idea
that it's only jesus and that jesus is
the father and he is the son and he's
the holy spirit
i don't think the bible teaches that we
have a book it's called the trinity
is it biblical and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number to call is 800-835-6747 that
is the free offer number
as for the book on the trinity it's
called the trinity is it biblical
you know pastor doug there are many
examples in the bible in the gospels
where jesus is actually praying and he
spends the whole night in prayer
and if he wasn't praying to a real being
if he wasn't praying to his father who
was he praying to
yeah you know it's just if you just read
the way the father
is pretty clear take this cup from me
are you talking to himself
no my will die will be done yeah yeah
absolutely
next what we have is gregory listening
from alabama gregory welcome to the
program
gregory are you there might be muted
gregory
hello pastor doug and pastor hello
pastor doug and pastor ross thank you
for answering my call my question
tonight
is how is jesus and god both the same
person
okay that's a good question similar to
uh
the question we had in the bible when it
talks about there is one god
keep in mind that when the lord talks
about being one
that god said a man gets married to his
wife and they become one flesh well
there's still two people but they're now
united
in their covenant the twelve apostles
jesus prayed that they might be
one and jesus is saying that he
and the father are one and what he means
by that
is that they are perfectly united in
their work of saving man now they've got
different roles
just like you might have a father and
mother that serve different roles in a
family
but they're one they're united in their
family and so
uh does that make sense yes it does
thank you
all right you would also enjoy the the
book that we just talked about and
you can read that with your folks how
old are you gregory
thanks so much i'm glad you're thinking
about these deep things of god
we'll send you that book on the trinity
yeah and also you know gregory you might
want to talk to your parents about
the amazing adventure set of lessons
it's good for for young people it's good
for people your age ten to twelve to
twelve to twelve yeah i think you'd
really enjoy it if you haven't seen it
yet
you can find out more talk to your
parents about looking at that at the
amazing facts
website next quarter that we have is
lisa listening from
oklahoma lisa welcome to the program
hello can you hear me we can
okay hi thank you for taking my question
um
so in mark and matthew it talks about um
the spirit is willing but the flesh is
weak
um and my understanding is
that the flesh is bad
like bad like who we are
and so my question is how then can we
strengthen the spirit
to overcome that flesh because i i
struggle
with so many of the different
things that you're not supposed to do
okay well
you first of all don't be discouraged
because that's sort of the
the struggle everyone faces um if you
read in romans
i now i just preached on this last week
and if you go to my facebook page you
can watch that sermon about the battle
between the spirit and the flesh i just
preached a whole sermon specifically on
your question so i hope you'll
anyone out there if you're wondering
about the battle between the spirit and
the flesh
you can just go to the amazing facts of
the doug batchelor facebook page
and we post and leave the sermons up
there we want anyone
who wants to be able to access the word
but if you look in romans chapter 8
it says for there is now therefore this
is verse 1
no condemnation to those who are in
christ jesus who do not walk according
to the flesh but according to the spirit
for the law of the spirit of life in
christ jesus now there's the key
living a spirit-filled life through
abiding in christ
the law of the spirit filled life in
christ jesus has made me free
from the law of sin and death for what
the law could not do and that it was
weak through the flesh
god did by sending his own son in the
likeness of sinful men and on account of
sin
he condemned sin in the flesh that the
righteous requirement of the law might
be fulfilled in us
who do not walk according to the flesh
but according to the spirit
paul describes the battle that people
face in romans chapter seven he says you
know
i i knew what i'm supposed to do but i
do what i don't want to do
and what i want to do i don't do and
there's this tug of war inside and
he sort of culminates in chapter seven
by saying
you know who will deliver me from this
body of death where we're struggling
the whole body is not all evil i mean
you know it's normal to feel hunger and
to satisfy that need
and if you're tired and you sleep that's
the flesh that's tired but it's not a
sin to sleep it's not a sin to eat
and if you're married sex is not a sin
and so these are
fleshly desires but the flesh is much
more than the physical aspect the flesh
is also talking about pride
it can be attitudes and thoughts so
the whole key for all of this is to be
born again
and be filled with the holy spirit and
as you read the word as you focus on
christ he abides with you and in you
and you end up becoming a new creature
but don't be discouraged if you find
that you're struggling and falling
that a lot of people in their walk with
the lord spend time going through that
well you know pastor i like the
illustration i think you might have
mentioned this in the sermon
that you preached a few weeks ago about
which nature are we feeding are we
feeding the carnal nature are we feeding
the spiritual nature and by spending
time in god's word
spending time in prayer spending time in
christian
gatherings and association we're
strengthening that spiritual nature
but if we're just feeding on the things
of the world
that's going to strength strengthen our
carnal nature that when temptation does
come
we can't resist it the way we should
that's right so uh we can do some
preparation
uh even before those temptations come we
do have a book it's called
tips for resisting temptation we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks it deals with the subject
the number call is 835
and again just call and ask for the book
it's called tips for resisting
temptation
thanks for your call lisa let's see
we've got uh timothy listening
from montana timothy welcome to the
program
good evening to you both how are you
both doing doing well thank you for
calling
good um my question is on acts 1
verse 26 okay we're going there now
and what do you want me to read that for
everyone yeah
okay and they cast their lots and the
lot fell on matthias
and he was numbered with the eleven
apostles
so what's your question about that yeah
so this is after just ascended
and they're talking about replacing
judas
and um it in my understanding of reading
the bible
um casting lots is something pagans do
not god's children so
can you explain why they did this
yeah well there are several times in the
bible where they did cast lots and even
at the instruction of the lord
now it can be sometimes a lack of faith
that people say i'm going to flip a coin
where you ought to pray and use good
judgment but when they divided the
promised land god told joshua to cast
lots
to see who would get so everyone knew
that you know
god was not being arbitrary it was being
fairly determined
um and uh when gideon
uh i'm sorry when
the apostles were picking uh gideon
didn't cast lots he did kind of throw
fleece out that's a little different
similar principle but
when the apostles cast lots they were
basically saying you know lord
we know we're down to 11 apostles you
specifically wanted 12 not 13.
and it's interesting that as soon as
they get 12 apostles the holy spirit's
poured out
um if you go to revelation and you end
up with 12 times 12
000 and when god gets this 144 000
there's a great spiritual revival so the
the
number 12 was important just like there
were 12 tribes in the old testament
there were 12
judges 12 princes of israel 12 is a
number that represents the leadership of
the church
so i think god wanted them to do this
you never hear from matthias again
in the bible i mean other than some you
know christian tradition he's not
mentioned in the bible again
but um it almost seems like
a couple chapters later god picks paul
yeah you know pastor i think one of the
reasons we do find
lots being cast at god's instruction in
the bible isn't so much because
you know the prophet doesn't know god's
will but perhaps it's to help
clarify for all of those who are looking
on
that this has been done fairly without
personal
bias yeah for example if you had paul
get up or peter i should say in the
upper room and say i think we need this
person
others might say well that's because
you're his good friend you know that's
yeah you know that's god's will but when
you cast lots it at least removes that
that any you know that there's no
prejudice or bias being involved
and that's maybe why although you know
practically speaking today
you know we probably need to be careful
in making important decisions by just
throwing dice and hoping for the best i
mean god has given us counsel in his
word
we can seek godly counsel from others
and pray that god would you know guide
us in the way it wants to go he leads
through providence too yeah
i have a a book that will send you a
free copy if you'd like and it's called
how do you determine the will of god and
it gives you principles and
casting lots is not one of them but it
gives you principles on how do you know
you know god's will biblically and i'm
going to call for that is 800-835-6747
you can ask for the book it's called
determining the will of god and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone in north
america
again that's 800-835-6747
and if emanuel would like that book and
he's in ghana africa well i'm sorry we
can't send you the hard copy but
you can go to the amazing facts website
just go to amazingfacts.com or dot org
and we have a free library and you can
actually type the name of the book and
you can read it for free right there
online
next holder that we have is let's see
we've got charlene
listening from california charlene
welcome to the program
thank you uh pastors i heard another
pastor
talking about eden being here on earth
and i know the cherubim was at the gate
but how long was eden here before it was
taken away
well you know the bible does not
specifically tell us
when eden was caught up to heaven it's
generally believed among most christians
that because the new jerusalem
and the tree of life are in heaven
that since god planted the garden of
eden he didn't want it destroyed during
the flood that just before the flood
he caught it up to heaven he plucked it
up you might say
just like you got the new jerusalem
coming down from heaven
in revelation 21 so god can move real
estate
he brought the garden of eden up because
the tree of life is in the new jerusalem
it's sort of the central park
of the new jerusalem and
so i believe the garden of eden is in
the in the city
and uh probably the time period he took
it up we know that it wasn't right when
adam and eve sinned because he left it
there and just guarded the weight of the
tree of life with
cherubim probably before the flood he
took it up
we have a verse in revelation chapter 2
verse 7 it says to him who
hears let him hear what the spirit says
to the churches to him who overcomes i
will give to eat of the tree of life
which is in the midst of the paradise of
god it's not of a tree of life
but it's of the tree of life so there's
one tree of life
that was the tree in the garden of eden
but as pasodeck mentioned it appears as
though that was taken to heaven sometime
before
before the flood and you know if you
think about the flood the purpose of the
flood was to
purify the earth from sin adam and eve
were cast
out or sent out of the garden of eden so
the garden of eden was still pure
and so there was no need for that to be
destroyed and it says right there in
that verse
in the midst of the paradise paradise is
another word used to describe
the garden of eden that's right all
right i hope that helps thanks for your
call charlene we've got uh
lily listening from canada lily welcome
to the program
hi thank you yes and your question
um so my question is if when we come to
christ and give our lives to christ
um our sins are forgiven so why do we
need to ask for forgiveness and repent
any time after that well
the bible talks and pastor ross might
have to look up the verse but it talks
in one place about
our past sins are forgiven in other
words when you accept jesus you're
coming to him with your past record of
sin
and you repent of your sins and he
forgives your sins and you begin to walk
in a newness of life
but then it tells us in first john
chapter 1 if we sin he's speaking to
christians if we sin
after that he is faithful and just to
forgive us our sins but
it tells us if we repent and confess of
our sins
in proverbs so when david sinned with
bathsheba he didn't shrug and say well
you know i repented back when i was 13.
i don't need to do it again
when he sinned with bathsheba he
repented again so
we need to keep short accounts with god
if if we
commit some you know known sin and the
holy spirit brings that to our attention
we don't we're not telling god because
god doesn't know
by confessing and repenting our sins
we're basically going on record that by
god's grace we want to be different
we're acknowledging it's wrong
we're apologizing for his specifics and
asking him to
forgive us you know the verse referring
to there is romans chapter 3 verse 25
that says when god set forth as a
propitiation speaking of christ through
his blood
to declare his righteousness for the
remission of sins that are past
through the forbearance of god so when
we confess our sins we're forgiven
but i think it has to do with attitude
if our attitude is well i confess that
sin way back when
and um you know i'm just going to keep
living my life and if i sin oh well
too bad you wonder about the attitude of
the person
if we realize what our sins cost god and
the suffering that it brought on jesus
you know we should feel
remorse when we sin and we would go to
the lord in prayer and say lord please
forgive me help me not to do that again
yeah whenever we do that it it basically
uh opens the way
for uh healing our relationship with god
absolutely and you know it's that way in
our relationships with each other if i
sin against a brother or sister
and i offend them i i you know it's
always appropriate to go to them and say
i'm sorry about this or that
and and you can heal the relationship
you can't say to your wife past the day
well you know i
asked for forgiveness you know 20 years
ago
i guess they won't put up with that it's
got to be a day by day experience
matter of fact the apostle paul says i
die daily and that's a good example to
follow
phil is listening from arizona phil
welcome to the program
hello pastor bachelor and ross this is
my first time calling so i thank you
i want one quick question i will say
thank you for um
i heard a past message you clarified my
view of god i used to be angry with god
because of hell but
my question is today's
church leaders that we see at the
forefront they seem to be
inconsistent with christ and
seeing us having a hard time you know
with all the information and all the
churches out there trying to figure out
you know what is the true representation
of god i i you know i
religiously follow your sights and you
made the bible so clear for me
and a lot of things i struggle with i
have no i
you know there's complete clarity uh you
know makes total sense you know just a
logistical tan standpoint so
my question is you know trying to
follow you know who are who are put
before it as leaders
um it just seems like there's so much
inconsistency
what's being said and what's actually
taught by christ
that's my question well you know
this is not a new problem even in
christ's day
when when jesus was preaching the people
were confused they said if he's the
messiah then how come most of the
religious leaders
don't get it they don't agree with that
well we better follow them
and you know moses said don't follow a
multitude to do evil
it's often been true through history
that
apostasy comes into the church and it is
the minority
that get it right martin luther be
through being a personal bible student
he had to stand up against
the majority of his associate priests
as did john calvin and as did
wycliffe and so many of the great
reformers they were catholic priests and
then they said you know
we're drifting too far from the bible
and as soon as they spoke up about what
the bible really said well they were
pariahs
in their generation so that's happened
so many times and it's still true today
that
you know typical evangelical
christianity
is a laughing stock for a lot of the
world they see these
evangelists begging for money promising
free pickup trucks and
and um you know wearing their their
gilded clothing and
and saying yeah send me your last twenty
dollars and then they laugh at uh
they laugh at a lot of the hypocrisy
don't follow the crowd yeah
that's right i mean the bible does give
us some some good practical steps
in in seeking good godly leaders and and
joining and being a part of
of the body of christ or the church and
we do have a study guide that's called
the bride of christ and it actually
gives you these various bible principles
and as pastor doug said the bible
doesn't leave us in the dark if we
follow those
biblical principles we will be led into
a clear understanding
and you know pastor even though you
might have a church that you know
believes the bible and is truthful
we still need to recognize that the
church is made up of people and we are
never to
follow just individuals or people
blindly
um even good people make mistakes we
need to follow christ
and follow these words so that that
needs to be our guide if you like
receive that study guide it's called the
bride of christ we'll be happy to send
that to anyone who calls and asks the
number is 800-835-6747 we'll get in the
mail
and i think you'll be blessed by reading
that we have ali listening in new york
ally welcome to the program
hey thank you guys so much for answering
my call thank you get real close to your
phone because your voice is a little
faint
okay sorry sorry um appreciate it i
thought
i wasn't gonna be able to get picked up
from everyone calling
but um my question is in luke 17
um verse five through six okay
go in there now yeah
and yeah got it you want to read that
you want to read it i can it says and
the apostle said to the lord
increase our faith so the lord said if
you've got faith as a mustard seed you
can say to the mulberry tree be pulled
up by the roots and planted in the sea
and it would obey you
so for me my question is um i know that
and we know that uh faith is the essence
of pleasing god in jesus because it says
it's impossible
to please god in jesus without faith
so is little my question is is little
faith
enough um how do we strengthen our faith
and
how can we relinquish any doubt
well the devil's always going to try to
bring in doubt
so you know you may have battles where
the devil's going to try and get you to
doubt the devil did that to jesus
usually faith is built upon evidence
that god has given us
most people don't have total blind faith
for out without a reason
uh even when david went to fight goliath
he told king saul
i believe i can kill that giant he had
faith he could kill the giant he said
because
god help me kill a lion and then again
god help me kill the bear
i think that same god can help me kill
the giant
and you know when we see god answer
little prayers
our strength our faith strengthens that
he can answer the bigger prayers
when we test his word and see that god
always is faithful to keep his word
and the bible is true our faith becomes
stronger and stronger in the word so
through the
study of the word through prayer through
experiencing god's leading
our faith grows you know i'm looking at
the verse passage romans chapter 10
verse 17
it says so faith comes by hearing and
hearing by the word of god we both heard
stories of people who
approached the bible with a very
critical attitude who thought well
there's no god and the bible's just a
fairy tale
but they actually started reading the
bible and as they began to read the word
their faith was
increased until they made a commitment
and a full surrender to christ
you found a bible in a cave when you
weren't really believing that the bible
was true
that's right and it made a difference in
your life and it's of course made a
difference in the lives of many others
so
if you want to increase your faith a
good place to start is spend
time in the word and study the bible
don't just read the bible but study the
bible and of course
find a good resource that can help you
do that and i'm thinking amazing facts
go to the website we have a free online
bible school that'll help guide people
and
by the time you get through that bible
school your faith will be strengthened
as you see the promises and prophecies
god's word
yeah and if you simply go to either a
bible universe
and you can sign up for the bible study
course there
go to the amazing facts website you'll
see the free bible studies that we have
but this whole ministry exists to help
get people involved in the word if
you've ever looked at the amazing
logo you'll see it is an
open bible we're trying to get people to
read the bible
that's where the transformational power
is well friends we just want to take the
last few moments of the program to
um remind you that amazing facts
is entirely supported by people like you
who are listening if you're hearing this
on the radio
it generally means someone in your
neighborhood is helping to pay
to put this program on and that's the
only way we stay on if you'd like
to keep us on the air and i know there's
thousands of good ministries out there
and you probably hear this announcement
many many times
but it is true we are kept on the air
by you and so we appreciate anything you
can do just go to the amazing facts
website
you'll find a place here click and
donate
and we trust you'll have treasure in
heaven thank you so much
for studying with us god willing we'll
be again together next week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
do you feel as though your world is
spiraling out of control
or perhaps new life challenges are
frightening you more than they should
are you
sinking while you're thinking excessive
worry can consume you
eating you from the inside out resulting
in sickness
insomnia and paralyzing fear it can also
damage relationships
ruin opportunities and yes diminish your
witness for the gospel
worry affects everybody differently but
it's all driven by fear
so how can you overcome a world full of
reasons to be anxious
i'd like to recommend for you my new
book finding peace in a world of worry
you'll discover a lifeline to victory a
place where you can
cast your cares upon christ and
experience a serenity
that isn't subject to your circumstances
get your copy of pastor doug's
finding peace in a world of worry today
call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
deep within the pages of the bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds
great love and great sacrifice
but behind them is another hero
hidden in plain sight amid the shadows
he was there from the beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven
throughout the entire bible tapestry
shadows of light seeing jesus
in all the bible get your copy today
by calling 800 538
or visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
did you enjoy this program make sure to
tell your family and friends
tune in next time for more bible answers
live
honest and accurate answers to your
bible questions